[Music]
hello my name is Julia I'm an Austrian
national I'm 28 years old and I work for
the European commission as an internal
for investigator I joined the European
Commission in 2018 so I've been here for
almost four years um initially I was a
trainee at Olaf which is the European
commission's anti Fraud Office um then I
joined the junior professional program
here I did two separate
stints so once I was at DG Sante which
deals with health policy and here I was
working as a lawyer and then I moved to
dgn where I worked in renewable energies
so two very different fields before
reintegrating back to Olaf where I now
work as internal fraud
[Music]
investigator I'm uh very much of an
advent support of the European project
and I think uh the causes that I really
care about for example diversity
inclusion the empowerment of minorities
and women but also climate change which
is a topic that's of high relevance for
my generation in particular are some of
the topics that the commission um really
cares about and that the EU really cares
about and I can see how we are working
on those topics and I can contribute
towards that so I see a lot of value in
my work and that's something I I really
love about my
[Music]
job what I really value about the
commission is that it's a very diverse
employer so I get to work with people
from across the EU in a variety of
languages I get to work with uh younger
people I get to work with more
experienced colleagues um I learn from
every single interactions and I also
like the fact that in the commission you
can work in so many different areas so
for example for me I started working in
anti fraud policy I have a background as
a lawyer in international trade law and
then I worked in health matters then I
worked in energy matters and now I'm
working in uh inter as an internal for
investigator so protecting EU Finance
and the EU budget so in my quite short
stt at the Commission in four years I've
already seen a variety of different
things and I know that there's more room
for me to develop upon that and to grow
with the commission as an
[Music]
employer